[Music]
he has a really concerning past and
current behaviors that are worrisome I
have two little sisters who are still
living at home who won't even be in the
same room as him what past are you
worried about he's had three restraining
orders filed against him oh there's that
lead with that next time
[Music]
kindall what is going on this is John
with the Dr John delone show so glad
that you're with
us I know this uh episode is coming out
um several weeks after but this is
launch week for the book you I know
y'all have been sick of me bringing it
up every episode but it's here it's out
into the Wild by the time you hear this
it will have been out into the wild for
a while um and the response has been I I
don't even have words for it I just went
home and ate tacos with my family around
our uh little island in the kitchen
Islands in the Stream that's right sat
and ate tacos last night because it's
just a lot and um it's overwhelming for
a little introverted who hangs out with
Nerds I'm just uh so grateful and I hope
that this this time after youall you
know by the time this thing comes out I
hope youall are reading the book and
starting to put some of those things
into practice and you're having some
hard conversations with yourself hard
conversations with your with your spouse
or with your boyfriend or girlfriend
you're having hard conversations with
your kids having a hard conversation
with the therapist but I hope you on a
path to create a different kind of world
but um just today just know I'm
overwhelmed with gratitude it's even
hard to it's hard to even breathe a
little bit um
but Kelly has poison ivy so it brings us
all down to reality I told you that
because you get poison ivy like I do
like you can see Poison Ivy and you get
it well I like go into the woods and I
get surprised every time I was in Texas
this weekend uh for the football game
that the Cowboys completely dominated by
the way who are they playing uh the they
played the Patriots gave Bill bich his
biggest loss ever just warm my heart my
little black tiny heart are the Patriots
like a glorified high school team this
year pretty much but anyway we will take
it we'll take it exactly all day long so
uh we stayed at an Airbnb and I had to
the door wouldn't unlock in the back
like it was supposed to so I had to go
around the front and I must have like
somehow there's some probably like three
blocks away that managed to get on my
ankle so here we are well here we are I
know whatever fun ruin. org. that hey oh
yeah it's questions for humans listen
it's been a whole week and I'm going to
try to sell you something else um qu we
got new decks for questions for humans
for Thanksgiving for Christmas and we
have a grandparents and kids deck coming
out um the Thanksgiving one may be sold
out by the time this episode airs but go
ahead and check it out um ASAP if you
want to get it here's the here's the
point I want I want to give you a tool
so you can go to Thanksgiving actually
enjoy your family and not talk about
politics or whatever other nonsense
Uncle Jethro wants to talk about so all
right let's do a question all right yeah
we got one for the booth um is there
anything you'd like to accomplish before
the year is over oh
man I
set I two things one um I want to
continue I won't talk about the ins and
outs of this but I want to
continue to create some space for me to
learn some new tools for interacting
with my daughter and and we're doing
that and so I have like a benchmark in
my mind the second thing is I kind of
have not kind of I put an
obnoxious um dollar amount goal to earn
through this year and so I we got to get
hustling I need to sell some books and
some questions for humans that's right
um but that's I mean that's those are
two one's a family goal and one's that
one what about you get rid of poison ivy
well I hope that's a a goal this week to
be honest honestly line is I've got to
start losing weight I got a very very
very Stern talking to from my oncologist
I'm four years uh post press cancer and
um she was like you have 40% chance you
lower your chances of reoccurrence by
40% if you lose weight why wouldn't you
do
that hey can I just can I say this can I
applaud your doctor oh I do yeah because
that conversation is not being had
across the country and I I know that's
hard hard to hear and I'm only telling
you that CU it's just a private
conversations between me and you and a
couple million of our friends but like I
good like that's a hard conversation
yeah right and and she said you would
kick yourself if it cancer came back and
you hadn't done everything possible and
I was just like damn yeah it was brutal
but she was 100% And I've known it but
she was 100% right and you know my
cancer was quote unquote easy and the
fact that I didn't have to have chemo
but next time might not be yeah and if I
can
do this anything to to save that off by
40% yeah okay let's talk after this
because I Circle back with my guys and
I'm on week three and it's pretty pretty
like this was the first couple of days
that it's been pretty
remarkable same team I I'll I'll I'll
walk you through what they told me
because um two guys told me two
different things this time that that I
don't know whatever it was it flipped
the switch for me yeah it's rough but
that's that's a goal I know I won't lose
it all by the end of the year but to
make some progress in that and to feel
better about that that's awesome good
for you about you Uncle Joe well she
stole my thunder uh she's not the only
doctor that is all over you know got to
lose some weight yeah so the goal is to
get below 200 okay and with the holidays
coming up hey it didn't gonna happen
yes we're choosing reality aren't we hey
we're gonna have a little uh meeting
we're going to have a little meeting cuz
we're going to get this thing dialed in
and um you're creating a human so no
well no but I my big goal that I need to
start doing is like yoga uh because baby
boys come in in February and I I need to
start doing some walk-in and yoga
something to like prepare me for that
and also just to help prepare my mind
mentally for what's coming two months
later after the end of the year so yoga
is definitely something that I need to
add into my
routine can you actually prepare for
this no no but myself you can prepare
physically like I think um I I've heard
it said The more like exercise you do
and the more walking the more physically
active you are it makes delivery makes a
difference yes but like the um I got to
prepare my mind for this I just think
there's no way you can't prepare your
mind there's no way because every birth
is so different everybody everybody's
experience is so different and I can
talk to so many different moms that have
done it and had multiple kids and
they'll say every experience is
different so it's kind of more of like
mentally preparing myself of what could
happen
rather than that's amazing yeah I I love
it good for y'all okay we're gonna get
this thing down we're gonna get it down
we're gonna get it down um Nate Dog yeah
I think that for me I would like to be
in the gym on average at least 3 days a
week very good uh I've had the past two
weeks where I've been in there every day
this week I won't because I'm coming
I've just came back from a work trip and
not going to happen but on average I
like to be days a week it
could it could happen oh yeah Nate Dog
today today let's do it all right it's a
so most of y'all I mean it's aesthetic
money wow we're a shallow Bunch aren't
we I'm totally playing no this about
getting your health back this is about
planning Legacy in future and this is
about um like preparing to add to your
family and preparing to continue to be a
better dad now I think all these are
really Noble good goals I didn't hear
one person be like I just want to get
some abs for spring break this is like
you know what I don't want to get cancer
like I want to live spring break yeah
we're adults sorry I don't know what
that is Whatever Whenever spring break
is and you have your like pom poms in
there like we've seen I'm heading down
to South Padre this year are you really
no yes you are all right let's when I
was 21 let's go to Hartford when you're
were 21 they didn't have South Padre
back then let's go to Hartford and talk
to Robert what's up
Robert hey Dr John how's it going party
man what are you up to not much uh just
excited for this call I'm excited to
have you brother what's up thank you I
appreciate it um so I'm calling because
I wanted to get some advice on how to
deal with my social anxiety o good good
question man all right
um so I want to can I walk through it a
little bit and teach a little bit about
social anxiety and then we can walk
through your particular situation of
course yeah all right so social ual
anxiety I want people to think about it
as your body's telling you that you're
not safe because you're constantly under
surveillance you're being judged people
are examining you people are watching
you right in the nerd world we call this
a negative examination the world is
looking at you and they don't like what
they see and you're never going to
measure up to a particular situation and
in some case uh like with social anxiety
disorder you can never measure up with
other people and that makes being around
other people EX
exhausting and excruciating so am I with
you there does that does that ring true
yeah definitely yeah okay and over time
you just get sick of being exhausted all
the time and so you end up slowly
withdrawing or finding ways around
groups of people or dealing with people
altogether even if you have a a skill
set in an area or a passion in an area
it's not worth um feeling like you're on
display and that everyone's judging that
display
um and sometimes that judgment's real
like U giving a public speech or um I
you're a physician right and you got to
meet in front of a bunch of other people
sometimes it's not it's a feeling that
everybody's watching you judging your
appearance or the way you walk or the
size of your nose or how close together
your eyes are whatever right and then
tell me if I'm on to something here
Robert then over time you start getting
anxious about being being
anxious yeah yeah definitely and then do
you have what I call um I I call it the
P the post anxiety drama so you are
anxious about this event I'm so anxious
I'm so anxious you go to the event you
think everybody's watching everybody's
listening that was such a stupid thing
to say and then the next six hours 8
hours are just consumed with replaying
and you judging basically like a film of
what just took
place yeah yeah like I shouldn't have
said that I can't believe I said that I
think they don't like me I think that
one person was really annoyed by me all
that does that sound right yeah and then
there's also the shame of like not
wanting to be the person who cares about
what people think so that's like another
layer on top of everything okay and
there's there's shame underneath that
too there's a couple studies out that
link uh social anxiety disorder and
shame so Landing with you
um we have a pregame analysis we have
the actual ah and then the postgame
analysis and during the pregame analysis
the pregame anxiety there's that shame
like I don't even care what they think
but your body's like you better and then
afterwards there's that shame I didn't
measure up I feel it I could tell yeah
yeah so let me ask you this growing up
who watched you or critiqued every move
or made a negative analysis of you on a
regular basis do you have somebody in
mind or a group group of people in
mind um I mean that's an interesting
question because I grew up in a very
Like Loving household I would say I
never really had to worry about whether
or not my parents cared about me or
loved me
so it I would I was always kind of like
an outsider at school okay and so I
would say if it was anywhere it would
most likely kind of like be from school
let me go one layer deeper um and this
is not an indict of how much your
parents loved you or an indictment of
how good your quote unquote your parents
were right M
um what was the attention to detail like
meaning in our house everybody's shirt
is tucked in there's a smudge on that
shoe go change your shoes fix your hair
this is ridiculous did anybody
withhold um almost a sense
of don't say that cuz dad's going to get
really mad if you say
that a sense of holding up the the the
the
family yeah that's a good question um
thinking about it I would say maybe that
existed like with my mom and
um like with her like religious beliefs
kind of um this is did it happen at a
religious institution like this is how
we act when we go here no she's kind of
like anti- institution like stay at home
and read the Bible kind of thing okay so
yeah your body didn't have a picture of
Mom and Dad going out and cutting it up
with other
people never I mean no I I don't really
have any memories of them being together
they got divorced when I was like four
okay and
um yeah they yeah I don't really have
any uh image of like what that would
look like yeah so uh just an interesting
this and again this is about curiosity
not judgment we're not mad yeah I just
want to ask myself and you can do this
off the call right and maybe spend some
time writing it down but I just want to
ask
myself did I get any messages either
explicit like hey those people will hurt
you or implicit like no crowds that's
where crazy people are it's we're not
driving after dark that's that's when
the drunks are out like we're like those
kind of messages that we get that
slowly close the doors to outside people
and then if you don't have a model my
dad is a cut up he's a funny guy and my
mom was always they always had people
over growing up and so I saw
interactions I saw goofiness I saw
people poking fun at each other I saw
disagreements and so then when I saw
that and experienced it at school I had
a context for it right right yeah if you
don't have a context for it and then a
group of people are like oh you're an
idiot and there's no your nervous system
can shut your body down right especially
coming out of a divorce yeah it it it
hits anyway I think those are
interesting things to flesh out but it
doesn't solve it gives some context but
it doesn't solve where you happen to be
right now so let me ask you this how
does social anxiety play out in your
everyday life now as an
adult so um it kind of manifests in like
my body and like I have all these like
physiological kind of symptoms when I'm
um in groups of people like that don't
really pose a threat but my body will
react as if it is like a major threat
like my heart will start to race and
I'll lose control of my breathing or I
will um like my voice will start to
shake and I don't want to present that
anxiousness to people so I hide from it
and then that avoidance leads to
isolation and loneliness and um and
you've probably heard me talk on the
show about it when when your body feels
anxious about something and you avoid
that thing that it made you anxious
about it actually reinforces that
anxiety alarm makes it stronger right
because it got because it won right it
got what it wanted so the next time
you're on people it's going to it's
going to ring earlier and it's going to
ring
louder MH and then you're avoid them
again and then just be like yes safe
again right and all the time you me like
you become really lonely and
isolated yeah yeah man all right so let
me ask you
this what do you think other people are
going to find
out
um probably
that those those symptoms that I
mentioned prob no beneath the symptoms
we're not going to blame the symptoms
those are the alarms what's underneath
that what are they GNA find out about
Robert that I'm not comfortable with who
I am or I'm not confident or I'm I don't
believe in myself okay underneath that
kind of thing what are you not confident
about that they're gonna find
out that's a good question it's like
when you peel the layers back it's like
what is even there
to feel that anxious about um well it's
they're going to find I'm not confident
okay yeah about what that you can't and
I'm just going to like if I'm playing
with a group of guitarists that are
really good I get anxious because I'm
not great I'm really good at rhythm
guitar and I'm really good at running
around on stage when it comes to playing
the weed lead stuff I'm not that great
and but I can I can fake it but when I'm
around a group of guitarists that are
really good like my buddy Nolan my buddy
will like going around those guys I
start getting a little angsty because
they're going to find out I'm not very
confident because underneath that
good and if I've attached I'm only worth
hanging out because I'm this
good then my body's going to sell the
alarms because I'm about to get excluded
I'm about to get kicked out of the
group right right so underneath your
lack of confidence underneath your lack
of what are what are you afraid they're
going to find out about
you or let me ask it another way what is
so bad about you that if they knew it
they would be like oh my
gosh I I really don't know I'll be
honest I've tried to do a lot of
reflection and figure that out myself
but like it's hard to it's hard to
really know if I'm honest
okay what are you so nervous they're
going to
see
um weakness I guess I guess that's what
those symptoms to me uh exhibit I guess
so do you see how this is a
ghost yeah yeah you're
nervous that they're going to see that
you're
nervous so your body gets nervous about
them seeing that you're going to be
nervous right the whole thing is a ghost
right it's a
ghost it's very very real and yet it's
not
there mhm
my guess is there's something deeper
though okay I've just done this long
enough like the old the great bery Brown
says shame eats secrets for breakfast so
my guess is there's some sort of secret
some sort of something that you are
afraid they're going to find
out and you don't have to say that out
loud here and you may not even know on
the top of your head what that off the
top of your head what that
is but your body is trying to protect
you from them for some reason okay so
here's what we're going to do and and
there's another question I want you to
ponder what is literally very
specifically what is the worst that can
happen right because when you walk down
that road usually it's oh nothing now if
you have social anxiety and you the
thought of public speaking terrifies you
and your boss says hey you got to give
the presentation at the board meeting
there's a consequence to that right you
can get fired or they may be like oh my
gosh you blew it that's for real hanging
out with friends on the
weekend maybe less for real right so
it's going to be context dependent but
asking yourself what do you think people
are going to find out what am I nervous
for them to see and what is the worst
thing that can happen literally very
specifically are they really going to
leave me good for them get out of my
life I don't want them
anyway what is it about me that my
body's trying to protect them from
finding out about and I think that's a
question worthy of exploration for all
of us what is my body trying to tell me
and so here's the thing um these are
little bits of CBT cognitive behavioral
therapy little bits of exposure therapy
there's some very clear clinical
practices here if you want to Robert to
go sit down with a counselor there's
very clear protocols for healing from
this okay um okay there is none zero
there is no path void of
discomfort okay exposure therapy is
about slowly opening the door a little
bit wider and a little bit wider and a
little bit
wider um if you have a phobia of snakes
what they'll do in the first couple of
sessions you'll talk about snakes then
in one of the sessions you'll draw a
snake then in the next session you'll
look at pictures of snakes at the end
you're going to hold us aive snake right
but we're going to slowly teach our body
we're okay here and we're okay here
we're okay here social anxiety will have
similar things but I here's what I want
you to do I want you to go today and I
want you to spend a little bit too much
money on it okay I want you to get a
journal of some sort and I want you to
call it a nonsense
Journal okay or a alarm system Journal
all right and I want you to write down
those thoughts as they start to spin
this will be a huge pain in the butt at
the beginning okay just know that up
front it's super inconvenient it's like
cting calories the first time it's
annoying and you have to recalibrate
your system I want you to write these
things down and begin to ask all right
I'm going to meet with three friends my
body's already spinning up what are you
scared
of of looking nervous well I feel
nervous so they're going to have to see
that eventually you may get to walking
in and being like guys I'm super nervous
to even be here I'm going to pull that
bullet right out of the gun before it
even goes off right right but we're not
there yet but I want you to begin to
write down those things and I want you
to be really honest what is your body so
scared for other people to see because
here's what I think I think you're a
pretty good guy thank you and I think
you bring a lot to an organization I
think you bring a lot to a group of
friends and I think somewhere along the
way your body picked up some messages
that aren't true that other people
aren't safe other people are what's
going to harm and hurt you so you got to
avoid them at all costs and at the same
time that's like depriving your body of
oxygen because we have to have other
people to survive so we're going to do
that and then the second thing is we're
going to Outsource some of this to one
or two friends that we really trust do
you have that in your
life I have my brother um and that's
kind of it is he
trustworthy yeah okay I'm gonna just put
this out there on the show because
um because it is what it is I've talked
a little bit about having body
dysmorphia most of my life like being
being weirded out by like never being in
shape enough or never having big enough
muscles or whatever the problem is
seeing something in a mirror that other
people don't see and so I know sometimes
when that flares up when I'm exhausted
when I haven't been taken care of myself
I'll put a t-shirt on and it won't feel
right and I'll look over at my wife and
say is this shirt okay to go outside and
she'll look at me and say
yes and I have outsourced that to her I
trust her implicitly and I begin to feel
what it feels
like because my body's saying it's not
you shouldn't wear this shouldn't wear
this it's too tight it's too small don't
wear this don't wear this and she said
you look great and so I'm going to begin
to practice feeling what it feels like
when it actually looks great and
sometimes occasionally she'll say no not
today and I don't get my feeling certain
I don't get mad I trust her and I'll
just I'll go change my shirt you see
what I'm saying I begin to Outsource
those things that are highly charged
highly emotional in me and so maybe
texting your brother before you go meet
with a group of for
friends MH think am I am I crazy no man
go have fun all right cool I feel a
little bit nutty right now but I trust
him I trust him so I'm going to go hang
out and what we're going to start doing
is practicing feeling that discomfort
and can I tell you one big spoiler alert
secret yeah no one's watching
you yeah yeah I know I know yeah
everybody so obsessed with themselves
and how they feel and how they look and
what they just said and what their hair
is doing
nobody's watching you and if anybody is
watching you they're watching you out of
Defense not offense they're watching you
to make themselves feel
better and God bless
them see what I'm saying yeah yeah
definitely I want you to protect against
that
shame that I shouldn't be feeling
nervous go with your body on it because
maybe you should maybe your body's
working just right for how it was raised
how it was trained growing
up maybe that maybe that feeling is
right
cool that kept us safe when we were
younger that helped us navigate a
divorce that helped us n navigate a mom
who kind of closed the door to the
outside world whatever that you it
helped us navigate a tough School
situation like you experience it's doing
its job I'm not going to feel ashamed
about that my body's working just as it
should but I got to teach us something
new because I want friends and I want
laughter I want Community I want
goofiness I want silliness I want ride
or dies I want people in my life that
means I'm have to be uncomfortable for a
season While I Work Into the Storm head
into the anxiety here um I do again
reach out to our friends at betterhelp
um reach out to a local counselor this
is there is some very um um concrete
research backed protocols for dealing
with social anxiety and you can work
through it if you choose to but I also
think you can start with a journal with
a close friend or two or a brother in
your case and some very
intentional
huh what's my body trying to protect me
from right now what am I so scared
they're going to find
out often the answer is going to be met
with a big smile nothing I'm
Robert I'm going to go hang out and have
fun I love you brother thank you for
calling we'll be right
[Music]
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey folks Delona here sometimes we
know what's good for for us but it feels
like we just can't make ourselves do it
like our brain's getting in its own way
and that happens to me a lot and I'm
pretty sure it happens to you I know I
should play a game with my kids instead
of practicing my guitar all night but
sometimes my brain tells me that hey
maybe that metal band's going to call
after all you got to get your practice
in therapy helps me figure out what's
holding me back from doing what I know I
should do and it can help you too so
your brain can begin to work with you
not against against you sometimes it's
just as simple as talking things through
and learning how to intentionally Place
guard rails between yourself and
negative behaviors we call them
boundaries so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give betterhelp a try
betterhelp is flexible because it's
totally online so it can fit your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist you can switch
therapist at any time for no extra
charge make your brain your friend with
better help visit betterhelp.com
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com all right let's go
out to the opposite of Texas Anchorage
Alaska and talked yeah that's right
Anchorage Alaska let's talk to Kendall
what is up
Kendall hi Dr John how are you doing
today partying what are you up
to not much
what's
up um so I I guess I'll kind of fill you
in on what's going on and then ask my
question um so my mom just started
dating uh after 11 years since my dad
passed away um and my mom says that uh
he makes her super happy and treats her
well but he has a really concerning past
and current behaviors that are
worrisome and I have two little sisters
who are still living at home who won't
even be in the same room as him and part
of that is
definitely um the change of my mom
dating for the first time but they voed
that they're not comfortable around him
and he hasn't shown much effort into
getting to know them and then the other
part of this is he has a lot to gain
from dating or possibly marrying my mom
she's not super rich but she has a lot
of assets and he um only has a
car so I'm just kind of looking for help
how old how old are you Kendall uh 22 22
okay how old are your
sisters um 18 and 11
okay
um what was your dad's
name uh Ed Ed was he pretty awesome yeah
you still have some good memories of
him yeah how'd he pass
away um sorry no it's
okay take your time I
he had a random heart attack while we
were all out hiking oh man I'm so sorry
when I was
11 my
goodness and so my mom was left as a
single mom with five kids after that
geez
wow and that's still right there at the
surface huh you miss him don't
you yeah it's been tough just processing
through someone else being there yeah
well that that's my first uh that was
going to be my first question sometimes
red flags
emerge just cuz this new guy's not my
dad and my dad was freaking awesome yeah
and it's easy to look at um I was just
talking to my buddy Jefferson this
morning when you're a kid like I have a
life before my kids right yeah my kids
don't I'm their whole life
life and now you're trying to wrap your
head around what who was your whole life
and then this just fog that's been the
last 10 years and then this guy shows up
right so you know that inherently
there's going to be some tension and
weirdness there right for sure okay um
so tell you said he's got a past what
past are you worried about um so he's
he's been married two times which you
know that's okay but
um he's had three restraining orders
filed against him oh there's that lead
with that next time
kindall um which what about with your
daughter I mean your sisters what are
they experiencing inside that home um so
there's a lot of there's a lot of
tension um a part of I think why they
mainly don't is my mom gets really
defensive of the boyfriend against my
sisters
okay um which since there training
orders he is sober which is definitely
something um but he also kind of acts
like a child
yeah um yeah when the government has to
step in and tell you to act like an
adult like a mature
person
um multiple times for crying out loud
I'll give you one if you have a bad
weekend right but my goodness um yeah so
why is your 18-year-old sister still
living at home
um she she's a little slower to adapting
the world I guess is the nicest way to
put it um int D intellectually or she's
just slow playing the
world just kind of slow very sheltered
okay um if your 11-year-old sister if
you offered to let her move in with you
would she do
that she's already joking about moving
out I know but she can't cuz she's a
minor but if she moved in with you an
adult or one of your other siblings um
you've got two other siblings somewhere
yes okay um would she be able to do
that um if it came to it probably okay
let's let's let's play this out that you
and your sister sat down with your mom
and you said hey I have invited little
sister to come live with me and I'll get
her to school and back and um I want her
to just experience this what what would
your mom say to that would she go oh my
gosh never or would she say I think
that'd be
best um she'd probably really freak out
and he he isn't living with her or
anything
MH
um but I think she'd really freak out
okay um it might come to that level of
seriousness if you have this much
concern a couple things I want to
caution you about not caution you about
but just expand your scope of what
you're seeing
number one it's not your
dad right right that's a big
one number and and nobody can ever live
up to the legend of that man that's in
your memory right right number two um he
does have a concerning past he
does very concerning past and as you
mentioned it sounds like maybe he's
putting the work in to make some
changes yeah my mom says he's he's going
to therapy and you know he's he's trying
to work through all of his past and his
hurt
okay um the third thing is we're going
to be very very concerned about the
safety of that 11-year-old girl yeah and
so um you and you have no legal
ramification at all unless you see
something that is concerning right you
hear about abuse you hear about
screaming you hear about somebody punch
a hole through the sheetrock you hear
about about taking your mom's money that
kind of stuff absent that I want you to
begin being very very intentional about
creating relationship with this
11-year-old we go to breakfast every
week once a week just me and her right
right and you're going to have to as a
22y old you don't have to you're a
sister but um sounds like you're super
invested which I'm proud of you um I
want you to invest heavily in the
relational side that way if anything
pops up you're the first call yeah and
you're a safe place your 18-year-old
sister I think you need to take her out
and say hey it's time we grow up real
fast you're 18 years old yeah this
little I'm just going to stay here
because the rent is free and because I
don't have to drive anywhere those days
are over now you're 18 years
old yeah and maybe she pays rent to you
and moves in with your apartment or
whatever the situation is but um I think
those are the different situ the
different conversations I'm going to
have with my sister right absent
breaking the law and absent abuse
um your 11-year-old sister canot like
this guy all she wants but your mom's
the adult and your mom's her guardian
yeah right and if he's following all of
his probationary you know restrictions
and he's following all the rules of his
restraining orders then it is what it is
yeah what you can do is strengthen your
two sisters with your relationship and
your presence being a safe place that
your mom maybe is is not right now yeah
does that sound
fair yeah and that's it's kind of what
I've been thinking and I've just been um
like not mean but very blunt with my mom
about things like he he came to the
house the other day and the 18 he was
like anybody home and the 18-year-old
was like no go away and he stormed out
of the
house and called my mom this is over I
can't handle the disrespect and d d
good good he should not be alone at home
he shouldn't be alone at home with an
18-year-old girl yeah and I think that's
the conversation with your mom mom he
has no business here being alone with an
18-year-old girl yeah oh he's not going
to do nothing he has no business being
here alone with an 18-year-old girl it's
not his
daughter yeah and if he had any brains
at
all he wouldn't walk in a front door
like
that right yeah
and so um maybe the conversation with
your mom is Mom I'm scared for you have
yall gone and just had like a lunch
together like a quiet or do it always
end up when there's an issue then it
turns into a
fight um I was thinking about taking her
out I just wanted to do this call First
and pick your brain yeah um but even
when I talk to her it's it doesn't it's
not like fighting she just kind of like
oh well he's a good guy so I think
there's something to be said for hey Mom
I can't imagine
how like in the depths of Hell lonely
you've been for the last
decade and maybe say I miss dad so much
this idiot on a podcast the other day
asked me about her oh no I said I wasn't
going to say I was an idiot anymore this
guy on a podcast um asked me about Dad
and I started crying I miss him so much
yeah and say Mom I know you're so so
lonely and I need you to know this guy
makes me really
uncomfortable yeah he makes me not feel
safe and if you say he's great and
wonderful and so kind and loving
okay but I need you to hear me say he
makes me not feel safe and I'm worried
about my
sisters that's a very different that's
you taking it as an adult woman that's
you owning your feelings you owning the
way you're experiencing this not saying
you need to be doing this and you need
to be doing that because if if you do
that to her she's going to have to fight
you
back
but if you sit down and say I have bad
vibes on this there's a bad track record
here I'm worried he's just trying to
take your money I I I just don't feel
good about it and also God you must be
lonely right both
and you're acknowledging the the the
just mess that she's been in for so long
right and maybe tell
her gosh
man you know what no one's probably told
her in 10
years how proud they are of
her yeah cuz the day after your dad
passed away she had to go be a mom to
five kids all by
herself then the day after that and the
day after that and then 10 years later
she's still doing
it yeah and there's something to be said
for holding your mom's hand across the
table and saying I'm like so proud of
you thank you yeah
right and sometimes when we're lonely we
go chasing somebody that will tell us I
see you got value he may see that she's
got value and assets right and things he
could take from her um or that she's a A
desperate woman and she'll you know
she'll make out with him or whatever
which I know it's gross to think about
your mom but she's a person too but he
he may you know he he may want to see
value other things but having her
daughter her adult daughter sit across a
table from her and just say no no no Mom
I see you but this guy makes me feel
uncomfortable um
that's a different conversation than
having a big disagreement in the house
or a big fight in the house or he storms
off and makes a call and she's
embarrassed so she bombs you guys that's
that's just this is just a different way
to handle it it may change nothing but
at least you know I did the right thing
and I I voiced what I was experiencing
as an adult in an adult mature way and I
treated my mom with dignity and respect
and yet I told the truth all of that is
to be
commended and continue to build
relationships with your sisters and hear
me say at the first sign of abuse at the
first sign of something's not right let
your mom absolutely know Mom I'm calling
911 I'm calling the police I'm not going
through you I'm not going through him
I'm going straight to the authorities
not going to have
any wonky play in my house and with my
sisters there I think just let everybody
know I'm Kendall 22 years old I'm
Standing Tall I'm going to adult woman
I've had a hard go of it I miss my dad
and I'm proud of my mom but I'm drawing
some firm boundaries in my life I'm
proud of you proud of you call anytime
let me know how that conversation goes
cuz I'd love to hear how your mom
responds to that my guess is she may
respond in a more receptive way than you
think proud of you we'll be right
back hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Hall is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com dealone today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free all right we're back um so we're
going to go with round number two we've
done a video series on the six daily
choices if you aren't watching this on
YouTube it's worth checking out we had
some really extraordinary
cinematographers and a film crew that
came in and did a masterful job
capturing some real life conversations
about the six daily choices today we're
talking about choosing connection one of
the most common themes I hear on the
show is I got nobody I'm so lonely I
don't know how to make friends I don't
even like the friends I got the friends
I have they don't really know what's
going on my spouse that I share a bed
with that I share kids with that I share
a checking account with he doesn't know
he doesn't know and so in this series if
you're watching this on YouTube check it
out if you're just listening to it on
podcast listen to on podcast and then
Circle back sometime and watch it with
your husband or wife or your partner
watch this um and listen to it this is
the
second daily choice of building a
non-anxious life choosing to live a life
of Peace it's off the grid that is
totally against culture right now this
is choosing connection check it out
so when I first started a podcast I put
a call out to people call with what's
going on in your mental health and your
relationships what's going on with your
kids people would call and they would
tell me this really intimate thing or
this really intense situation my first
question was often why are you calling
me call your friend have you talked to
your wife about this and without fail
every single person responded with one
terrifying response man I got nobody
else to call
so here's what's Wild we communicate
with more people than any other humans
have ever communicated in the history of
this planet we have more people in our
orbit than ever before and we are the
loneliest generation that has ever
walked this Earth and if you're like me
over the last decade I have found myself
communicating more and more and more and
my body's been feeling less Les and less
connected
communication is not
connection technology it's great where
are you who are you how's your mom but
technology does not permit connection
for the first time in human history we
are tribess
people we've pulled the thread on every
one of the things that bound us together
we've pulled the thread on education and
on medicine and on politics we used to
lean on these important pillars of our
society and they're
gone and we're left with these shiny
Little Boxes full of people who hate the
people we hate and who like the things
that we like and we're living in these
splintered realities and here's what's
wild about how our brains work when your
brain identifies that you're alone when
your brain understands when your body
feels and knows that your tribe has left
you it instantly divides the world up
between us as and thems it looks for
people who are just like you in order to
stay safe we need an us and everyone
else becomes
them you ever wonder why 40-year-old
guys get together and they've been
friends since high school and they just
tell the same high school football
stories over and over
again because for most of us that was
the last time we were a part of
something bigger than ourselves elves
and then we graduate then we get out of
the military we walk across that stage
and without warning it suddenly in an
instant becomes the world verse me if I
make a sale it's because you didn't if I
win it's because you lost and our bodies
go to war and you're busy at work and
you're busy at home and you're busy
keeping up with the Joneses and now that
we have smartphones every everyone is
the
Joneses and we're running and running
and running and we wake up and we're 33
or we're 41 or we're 29 or we're 55 and
we have no
one and this isn't me just spitballing
I'm not just making this up in 2022
Ramsey Solutions ran an extensive survey
across the country just trying to get a
state of people's relationships what we
found was devastating 82% of people said
the people they spend the most time with
have no idea what's really going on deep
inside almost 70% have three or fewer
close friends over 50% more than half of
the respondents said they did not have a
single person they felt safe enough to
call in the middle of the night if they
had an emergency of course our bodies
aren't letting us sleep of course our
bodies don't want to be intimate of
course our bodies all have digestion
issues because they are trying to not
die because we have no one when's the
last time any of us truly felt like we
[Music]
belong a life of loneliness is a
choice choosing loneliness is choosing
to live a life of
anxiety choosing loneliness to be honest
is choosing to die early loneliness has
been implicated clinically and
everything from heart attacks to cancer
to dementia increases your risk for
addiction for suicide for mental health
challenges and when you choose
loneliness and you choose to die early
you're also choosing to take everybody
else down with you cuz your kids are
wondering what was so bad about me that
Dad didn't reach out what was wrong with
me what was so bad about me that my wife
wouldn't tell me what was in her heart
choosing loneliness is choosing misery
and you got to hear me say this you are
worth so much
more and so where do we go from here
where do we go what I'm going to say
sounds like flowers and rainbows and
little blue birds fluttering around our
heads I get it I know the path forward
the path towards choosing connection is
you have to choose
love I remember asking a buddy who was
an active Navy SEAL you'll love each
other when you're out on deployment he
responded with a unique and special kind
of love it's a kind of love that will
lay your life down for somebody else who
will say if not me then who it's a love
that says all go first it's a love about
purpose love doesn't mean soft and love
doesn't mean weak and love doesn't mean
giving up your power and love doesn't
mean having no boundaries this is rooted
in Neuroscience love calms the body love
connects you are who you are in space
and within your own body because you are
connected or because you're disconnected
because you were loved or because you
were unloved so we have to understand
that most of us don't have good models
for connection most of us don't have
good pictures of what love even looks
and feels like for most of us love came
at a cost we got love when we achieved
we got love when we acted right we got
love when we made other people look good
or other people feel good and that's not
love when a body is loved when a body is
connected the body can be at peace
otherwise you are running around as an
anxious chaotic mess love is the
foundation of a non-anxious life it's
the foundation of connection you are
fully
seen and you are fully heard and you are
known and you're loved
anyway so what do you do if you don't
have a good picture you don't have a
good model but you know you got to I
want you to think of love and connection
as skills things you got to practice
things that you don't know how to do but
that you know you got to learn and
making new friends as an adult is the
worst it's the worst how can you ever
recreate the friendships you experienced
in your sorority and your fraternity you
can't those are special and unique the
challenge isn't recreating what already
existed the challenge is building
something new some practical steps
towards connection some practical steps
towards love show
up volunteer go first if somebody says
hey I'm moving this weekend just say
I'll be there but the best time to start
being a friend is right now and the
non-anxious person rejects loneliness
the non-anxious person pursues and
chooses love and connection and
friendship you have to decide however
uncomfortable it might be that you're
not going to do life alone there is no
other
[Music]
way hey what's up delone here listen you
and me and everybody else on the planet
has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non- anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
dooney.com
all right we're back that was choosing
connection as we wrap up today's show
the song of the day it's from the great
Kenny Rogers
Islands in the Stream featuring Dolly
Parton what what's Dolly's
nickname I don't I don't is it like the
queen of country music or is I think she
is the Lord does she have like a yeah
she's just like the greatest human ever
to live ever ever anywhere yeah better
than everyone else that's ever been aive
when you talk to people in Nashville
that like work with her and know her
they talk about her like she's the
greatest human who's ever lived she said
happy birthday to me one time at a
restaurant oh yeah yeah was a big moment
it'd be so funny if there was this older
woman right now just having brunch with
her friends and she's like I told this
lady I was Dolly and she fell for it
well they were they were doing her
niece's birthday we were at a nice
restaurant and then they brought me out
of we were like a few tables over and
she walk over and said well happy
birthday honey and I was just
like and then you you instantly got
poison ivy like every was awesome I
would I would actually love that that'd
be cool Islands in the Stream baby when
I met you there was peace unknown I set
out to get you with a fine tooth comb I
was soft inside there was something
going on you do something to me that I
can't explain hold me closer and I feel
no pain every beat of my heart we got
something going
on Tender Love is Blind it requires a
dedication all this love we feel needs
no conversation I just have this picture
of like a wood panel house in a fire and
like a bare skin rug and like a dude
with a real hairy chest just like saying
these
lines we ride it together aha making
love with each other Aha and he's got a
cigarette Islands in the Stream it's
what we are no one in between how can we
be wrong sail away with me to another
world and we rely on each other
ah from this line from one lover to
another aha justy
but also perfect love you guys see
you